I want to talk about this too this is
from uh AP News toy company Mattel
revealed its first Barbie doll
representing a person with Down Syndrome
on Tuesday Mattel collaborated with the
national Down syndrome Society to create
the Barbie and ensure the doll
accurately represents a person with Down
Ben's Down syndrome the company said
design features of the new Barbie were
made under guidance from ndss Mattel
said in addition to portraying some
physical characteristics of a person
with Down Syndrome the Barbie's clothing
and accessories carry special meaning
the blue and yellow on the doll's dress
accompanied by butterflies represents
symbols and colors associated with Down
Syndrome awareness they also wear the
Barbie also has ankle foot Orthotics
which some Down syndrome children use
Good Morning America had a segment on
this you could see the Barbie let's
check that out
and I'm here whenever there's ever
Barbie with a thousand times and it's
like me and it's beautiful and I laugh
it to pieces
[Music]
I love it
nice yeah what do you like about it
um the hair out of the clothes
we brought the dolls Down syndrome to
life in close partnership with the
national Down syndrome Society through
this collaboration we were able to
ensure the doll and all the design
elements and details were an accurate
representation of a person with Down
Syndrome
[Music]
foreign okay so here's here's what I
want to say about this because I've seen
some conservatives making fun of this
and calling it woke it's another woke
inclusive uh PC thing is what some are
saying and and I'll admit that in the
first moment
after I saw this headline I almost had
that reaction because I saw the term
inclusive Barbie doll and my first
instinctive reaction is to roll my eyes
because 99.9 of the time it's going to
be something stupid uh if there's an
inclusive whatever it's something stupid
it could be something or it's gonna be
something actively objectionable or both
you know like a um whatever a non-binary
Barbie doll or something if they don't
already have that I'm sure they're going
to soon enough
but then there's the 0.1 of the time
when it's actually something good and
this is the point one percent
we don't want to be like dogs you know
barking whenever we hear a car in the
driveway no matter who's driving it we
want to have discernment
right and and we should have it here
Down syndrome people
really do need to be included we need we
do need inclusivity campaigns for them
because Down syndrome people especially
children are being excluded from society
in the most violent and bloody ways
they're being exterminated by the
abortion industry that's a big reason
why they run tests for Down syndrome in
utero because uh you know they run the
tests and then they give the parents the
option to kill
the child if they don't want to have a
child with Down syndrome and tragically
many parents do Biden's plans to help
struggling business owners in the wake
of covid lockdowns were to prioritize
black latino Native American and
women-owned businesses it goes without
saying that if the roles were reversed
and Biden had said his plans were to
prioritize white male-owned businesses
well there would have been outrage so if
you own a business you can't rely on the
government to bail you out you need to
take matters into your own hands and
Innovation refunds can help you do just
that if your business has five or more
employees and it managed to survive
coven you could be eligible to receive a
payroll tax rebate of up to twenty six
thousand dollars per employee through
the employee retention credit just go to
getrefunds.com Innovation refunds has
already helped clients claim over three
billion dollars in payroll tax refunds
through the ERC and they may be able to
help your business too this is not a
loan there's no payback it's a refund of
your taxes there's no upfront charge
either they don't get paid until your
business gets its refund don't let this
opportunity pass you by see if your
business qualifies for ERC assistance in
just eight minutes go to get refund
funds.com click on qualify me and answer
a few questions this payroll tax refund
is only available for a limited amount
of time so don't miss out go to
getrefunds.com getrefunds.com
the weather is warming up here in
Nashville you know what that means it's
barbecue season I don't want to brag but
I make a pretty mean Burger the last
thing I'm going to be doing when I'm
getting ready to host a barbecue is
driving around worrying about where to
refill my propane grill tank that's why
I'm a huge fan of cinch cinch is a
propane grill tank Home Delivery Service
they deliver your propane tanks right to
your door cinch delivers on on your
schedule doesn't require any long-term
commitment or subscription plus delivery
is completely contactless you don't have
to wait around at home you don't have to
make awkward small talk with anyone they
just come and they drop it off and
that's it you can track the order on the
Cinch app from anywhere whether you're
grilling for the sweet baby gang camping
with your family or lighting up your
fire pit on a cold summer nights cinches
propane delivery service ensures you
have the fuel you need to make the most
of every moment so go online to
cinch.com or download their app now to
order new customers get their first tank
exchange for just ten dollars with promo
code walls go to cinch.com or download
the Cinch app and use promo code Walsh
to get your first tank exchange for just
ten dollars that's
c-y-n-c-h.com promo code Walsh this is a
limited time offer you must live with an
essential service area to redeem it
visit cinch.com offer for details
so
if we're doing anything as a society I
would say to include
Down syndrome children to humanize them
represent them that's a good thing it's
pro-life actually it is pro-life the
correct and also strategically
intelligent reaction for conservatives
from something like this is to say wow
is pro-life they're putting out a pro
something pro-life this is great
now
does Mattel mean it that way okay did
the Mattel the corporation and they're
in their marketing department their toy
Development Department whatever and
they're sitting around did they say hey
what can we do to advance the pro-life
cause
well obviously not and they would be
horrified probably if we took it that
way and so if conservatives started
coming out and saying this is pro-life
this is amazing this is great uh Mattel
would not be happy about that
but we should do it anyway
like take the wins where they come even
if they're unattention unintentional
even if we're seizing on to something
that was meant a certain way
and we're saying nope this is what it
means you might not have meant it this
way but this is what it means
and this is a perfect example of that
whether you're intend for it to be
pro-life or not whether that's a
conscious intention it is
because to include and humanize and and
represent again I know these words have
connotations now and every time we hear
them we have that instinctive
um reaction to it but
there are contexts where these words
really do mean something even if they're
misused most of the time and in this
case yeah if uh representing and
including Down syndrome children a very
good thing and also look it it's true
that if you're a parent
with a child who has Down syndrome the
shows that your child watches the movies
the toys that he plays with he's not
going to often see people like him
in those contexts
partly because again Down syndrome
people are being eradicated in an actual
Eugenics campaign that's happening in
this country and Across the Western
world
so I can imagine that if I had a
daughter with Down Syndrome
um I'd yeah I'd be going out and buying
this doll for her
and it would be extremely unfair
uh and annoying to say the least if I
heard conservatives accusing me of
participating in something woke
because of it
it's uh it's not and we need to be we
need to be smarter than that I think
that'll do it for this portion of shows
move over to members block become a
member today by using Code walls to
check out for two months free on all
annual plans
um
see over there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]